[Música]
bienvenidos a esta edición de enlace
norteamérica es un gusto saludarlos
desde washington en esta edición
hablaremos sobre la reciente
investigación contra el ex presidente
donald trump que llevó al allanamiento
del fbi a su residencia de la florida el
mar al agua les contaremos que se conoce
y que no sobre el material encontrado el
8 de agosto también hablaremos de las
consecuencias legales que puede
enfrentar el ex presidente por haberse
llevado información confidencial y qué
opinan los estadounidenses en las calles
sobre las amenazas y los ataques contra
el fbi tras la redada
[Música]
según archivos nacionales de longchamps
se llevó de la casa blanca a cerca de
700 páginas de documentos confidenciales
al terminar su presidencia autoridades
calculan que sólo ha devuelto 300
documentos a pesar de que el actual
gobierno lleva más de un año pidiéndole
que regrese la información confidencial
la falta de cooperación y el carácter
confidencial de los documentos llevaron
archivos nacionales a informar al fbi
que terminó llevando a cabo el
allanamiento en málaga
la sensibilidad de los archivos
encontrados inicialmente llevó a que el
8 de agosto el fbi y rescatar a 26 cajas
con documentos clasificados y 11
archivos catalogados como secreto de
estado
según el affidávit publicado la
información recuperada estaba en
desorden y mezclada con artículos de
periódico fotos y otros escritos según
el fbi hay causa probable para creer que
el material sustraído contenía datos que
comprometen agentes de inteligencia así
como información de seguridad nacional
altamente confidencial sin embargo
aunque el departamento de justicia haya
publicado la orden de allanamiento y
redactado el affidávit lux se conoce
todavía cómo se manejó este material
confidencial y si fue transferido a
terceros tampoco se conoce cuál es su
contenido completo y si trump todavía
tiene más documentos por devolver
una de las preguntas más relevantes es
si se presentarán cargos o no en contra
de trump tras las investigaciones que se
adelantan en su contra algunos analistas
opinan que aún cuando recaerán
consecuencias legales contra trump o
políticamente el exmandatario podría
sacarle provecho de cara a las
elecciones legislativas y presidenciales
del 2024
libres manera de ser fijas si puede
recaudar donaciones usando el escándalo
si ya lo está haciendo pero que eso le
ayude no a nivel legal a lo mejor
políticamente pero veo un problema con
eso también si yo fuera republicano
aunque recauda fondos de sus
simpatizantes
ahora los va a tener que usar para su
defensa legal y no políticamente
asumiendo que puede hacer eso al final
es un dinero que se pierde para las
campañas republicanas a dos meses de las
elecciones al congreso lugar a partir de
lo que indica la orden de allanamiento
el trump podría afrontar cargos por
posible violación de tres leyes
federales la primera es la ley de
espionaje la segunda obstrucción a la
justicia por no colaborar con archivos
nacionales y tercero la toma ilegal de
documentos gubernamentales en respuesta
a la investigación tromp pidió que se
frenara la revisión del material y se
nombrará un maestro especial para su
verificación sin embargo el fbi ya
revisó todo el contenido de las cajas
encontradas en mar al agua y seguro el
departamento de justicia esa ya no sería
una opción legal para el exmandatario
la respuesta legal de trump ha venido
acompañada por una contestación pública
en sus redes sociales que ha exaltado
aún más la polarización en el país
cuatro días después del allanamiento un
veterano de la guerra de irak atacó la
sede del fbi y en cincinnati agentes del
fbi han recibido amenazas contra sus
vidas se les ha comparado con la gestapo
nazi llamados a desfinanciar la
organización a ponerle bombas al
edificio central del fbi en washington
hay quienes hablan de una guerra civil y
una rebelión armada estos mensajes se
publican en sus shows o en la red social
que creó el expresidente trump tras ser
bloqueado en twitter el clima político
elevado impulsó al presidente bailén a
dar un discurso a nivel nacional para
promover la unión la democracia y el
respeto a la fuerza pública y las
instituciones
al respecto hablamos con las personas en
las calles en washington para
preguntarles su opinión sobre el
allanamiento en mar a lago y si creen
que existe una crisis de credibilidad en
las instituciones
era justificado que entraran allá para
ver que tenía trump él no estaba
entregando la información sobre los
documentos que tenía en su clóset
no creo que haya una falta de
credibilidad en las instituciones en
eeuu
profesional tipo creo que las personas
que trabajan en las organizaciones del
estado son profesionales entrenados a
hacer su trabajo sin importar la
situación política
no creo que esto sea un tema político
creo que es un tema de cumplimiento de
la ley ni las elecciones legislativas en
noviembre y las presidenciales en el
2024 definirán el futuro político de
eeuu tanto demócratas como republicanos
mueven sus fichas políticas para
mantener o recuperar el poder
trump que salió de la casa blanca hace
casi dos años y tiene más de cinco
investigaciones legales el proceso sigue
siendo protagonista de la política
pública en eeuu y juega en ese sentido
sus escándalos e investigaciones parecen
mantenerlo vigente y le ayudan a seguir
construyendo una masa de simpatizantes
que lo financian y que votarán por él en
el 2024 si se presenta la presidencia
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición de enlace norteamérica desde
washington pueden enviarnos a nuestras
redes sociales comentarios y sugerencias
de temas que les gustaría exploremos en
los próximos capítulos los invito a
seguir con la programación de france 24
en español hasta pronto
[Música]